so this morning we we heard three great
talks about inferring demographic
histories from a little frequency
Spectra and while these have been the
spect had been very effective at
inferring demographies in the Deep past
H we are slightly more interested in
more recent events so H we we use a
different kind of approach based on H
type sharing
and other groups as well as are
have been using the Workhorse of
identity by descent and between
individuals in a in a cohort and as
Monty slatkin explained eloquently
yesterday when you have a when you have
uh siblings cousins and more remote
relationships between individuals um
occasionally you would see the ancestral
alos of the founders of these two
lineages in in the um in the two
descendants to remote relatives at the
same and when that happens at the same
Locus these regions are identical by
descent now when these are long enough
we can observe them um as identical by
state um and so Kelly Harris and R sson
are in the audience and they made uh
this the great contribution of and it
really the suffering identifi by state
tracks into um identif by descent
regions H we're going to U we're going
to simplify things and assume regions as
that the regions that are identical
identical by descent uh during this talk
um f first of all because it's simpler H
second of all um when we're looking at
regions that are long enough and with
very recent common ancestor the it makes
more sense uh to make that assumption
and last but not least while when
looking at data it's hard to generally
say that a region that's identical by
state is indeed identical by descent
when you simulate the data you often can
do that
um so in
um um beside this introduction uh we're
going to review uh the uh the model for
what it means to be identical by descent
in a population and how does that help
us to infer infer demography um we'll
extend the model from a single
population to multiple populations in
incorporating migration into the models
we can actually look at some data from
the genomes of the Netherlands project
and finally hopefully we'll have time
to um to consider the the large amounts
of sequencing data and how they er might
be incorporated in identi by descent
analysis analysis that was invented in
the dark ages of the snip
World okay so um let's start with uh
with quantif
identity by descent and very clearly if
you if you know the relationship between
individuals things are things are easy
uh siblings
share share half their
genomes and the they share that half in
very long track and the
farther apart are the individuals the
more remote is the relatedness between
individuals h the fraction of their
genome that they are expected to share
um um Decay is exponentially by a factor
of four every generation because a site
needs to
survive each of the Transmissions across
the the two lineages and the the
expected length of the segment also uh
decays but decays only linearly because
the the length of each tracks is till
the next recombination site and the
recombination
events areound process for intents and
purposes so it can be the the distance
to the next Rec comination site is
exponentially distributed with a
expectation that is reciprocal to the
number of generation to the common
ancestor so if we know the the time of
the common an everything is simple but
um given all that we know about
coalescent Theory we know a lot about
the time to come and answer in in a
cartoon right Fisher population of a 20
individuals
U the time to come an answer is really
the the first coalescent event going
back in time um and are closed forms for
that um in this case or in comple more
complex demographic demographical
histories for instance exponential a
growth from uh starting population
ancestor population of size AAL 5
ancestors here to a current size 20
individuals at present during uh g
equals three generations that this
passes may have
taken um
importantly whenever you have some model
some parametric model in
mind for defining your population
history that allows you to um to uh use
these parameters and
um and and start inferring a demography
by inferring the uh the parameters that
will give rise to the data the most
likely parameters that uh that will give
rise to the data um
the the missing piece is really um
providing a providing the likelihood to
uh to the observation to the observe
data of multiple segments of identi by
descent segments of different lengths um
the uh F the key statistic here is the
um length of a segment of a identi by
descent around a randomly Cho chosen
Locus um between a pair of individuals
and if you consider a random chisen
Locus then you need to walk a to the
five Prime as well to the three prime
end
um um till the next re combination site
um and find the total length between
those sides so if you do
know the time to the common Anor the you
know that the um and then everything is
simple and what we don't know
is is
the
um is when that common had had really
existed so we need to uh we need
to sum over all all all options for that
common an store
and uh apply base
rule in order to get just the the total
probability for Segment within any
particular length interval between
between u and
v um
further the composing this this
expression the the left hand power is
just a coalescent theory is just the
chance of a common Anor being K
Generations ago given the given Theta
the parameters that we assume regarding
population history the right hand side
is also simple um we need to tally the
two exponentially distributed random
variables that that measure the distance
from the current site till the next
recombination
site
um so it's it's an a
longitud distribution which which
whatever whatever assumptions this would
still what whatever assumptions we have
about the demography this would still
hold
um so
it's it's instructive to look at
specific cases specific simplifications
specific assumptions to see what we can
get out of this model and of course
nothing is simpler than a than a right
Fisher um and if you assume a constant
population size everything is closed
form um as we've seen over the last
couple of days if you're really Brave
you can open up mathematic live and and
solve this if you're really smart you
can do that on the Whiteboard if you're
nether you can just recite
the the result and um and get the get a
closed form for the um the chance of two
individuals having a segment of length L
um between
um between length u and v um at a random
point along the
genome so you can think of of
that of that statistic also as the
fraction of the genome that would be in
such segments segments within that uh
range of
intervals um and so let's uh let's call
that uh that fraction F of uvf of that
interval and we can consider the expect
the expected fraction given that we know
the ancestor had lived K Generations
back in time or if we
don't the
expected expected fraction of the genome
in segments within that interval just
given the parameters that we assume
regarding the population the population
demography um so we can rewrite that and
a very useful case is when we're
tallying up
all the segments that we observe from a
particular length cut off and onwards so
um when we take the right hand side of
the of the interval to Infinity so we
can estimate or observe just the
fraction of the genome in in a data set
that's in segments of a particular
length and onwards this is practically
useful because a
if we limit ourselves to things that we
can detect then we often have that kind
of a a length length cut off
and for the for the constant population
size case this translates to an to a
close form
estimator for the effective population
size
um the um for more complex cases you can
follow the same rationale if you have
some parameterization of population
history uh you can we can try solving
the the relevant the relevant integrals
in some cases we we can do that the most
General case is of an arbitrary
population size at each generation so we
have uh a
function n of a K and that tells us what
is the population size K Generations
back in time
um people may prefer a continuous
formulations or um or
discrete formulation for the coalescent
coalescence process
and but I think because we're
considering Rec combinations and later
on mutations the repat formulation is
actually is actually helpful The
Continuous time um analysis it relies on
the fact that the events you're
interested in are coalescent events if
those are the only events then then
that's that makes sense as the as the as
the clock but when you have several
different clocks that work at different
rates the I think it becomes even more
convoluted so we we try to keep
the the actual generation time as
the as the clock
here so um most generally you can assume
um any population size at each point
when you go back in time and standard a
standard coalescent Theory will tell us
the um the distribution of the time to
common answer given that
distribution um and we can plug that in
though um at least theoretically we
still need to um to tally this summation
to Infinity um in practice um you can
make the simplifying assumption that you
don't need to go beyond a certain point
or um uh for or formally the that the
population size is of a particular of a
particular magnitude from some point in
the past and further back and which is
how we how we forly deal with that H the
the outcome is that you have a finite
number of terms here so even if you
cannot get a um um even if you cannot
get an invertible expression for the for
the for the population size or for data
you can definitely get likelihood from
any kind of formula any kind of uh
description of population sizes in the
past um so we spent we so far looked at
the a fraction of the genome that is
within segments of identi by Descent of
a particular length range that's a
useful statistic but not the only one um
a specifically this is a choosing so we
were so far we're thus far choosing a
random site along the genome and asking
what's the chance of that being in a
particular segment of a particular
length um in many for many uses we're
looking at multiple segments and we may
be choosing different segments and
asking what is the distribution of
length of the segments that we actually
see so each segment is weighted once
rather than being weighted according to
its length H in order to compute that
quantity the distribution of the length
of of actual segments we need to of
course
normalize the the the contribution of
segments of particular length by the
length of that segment and and then
normalize this expression uh by the
overall fraction of by by the overall um
tally of of this P of L given Theta
divide by L it Ted across all all
possible L's and and again while this is
a general formula you can substitute for
for a particular assumption in this case
for the for the right
fishal uh get um and get a particular uh
closed
form um the
another useful term is the just the
number of such
segments that you may observe in a data
set and that's that's helpful because um
in many cases you have fuzzy edges uh
there's some work by by gim F group that
deals with that formally but regardless
um a perhaps more stable number is just
the number of segments that you observe
um the all you need to do is to um take
the fraction of the genome that's
um that's in such segments and multiply
by the length of the genome that we note
here by gamma and divide that by the um
by the expected number of such segments
this requires making the assumption that
uh that these two quantities are that
the number and and total lengths of
segments are are independent H it's of
course false but uh at least for
segments that are far enough apart along
the genome this uh this is useful and
there are um and there a there's a paper
from 2011 that makes that claim more
more
quantitatively
um so so we can get an approximate
number of such segments
and and you can uh you can do some
additional manipulation uh to get a full
distribution of this number basically we
can assume this number to to be Plus on
given that expect ation and get the full
distribution of the total fraction of
the genome that two individuals would
would
share in segments of a particular range
of
lengths so so far for
the for
the perhaps Baseline ER theoretical
framework for a single population of
course when we when we look at
data more often than not we're
interested in modeling not just a single
population but multiple multiple groups
of individuals in context and and
specifically when we're contacted by The
genome
Netherlands
people the data set consisted of
multiple provinces which we so we went
to to develop the the framework for
analysis of multiple populations
multiple
thems um so the the key is that instead
of
considering the the chance for
coalescent in a single population we
need to replace that with what you get
from from two distinct populations and
of course when the populations are
completely separate it's it's not really
interesting nor practical
um it's it's much more much more
relevant to assume some kind of
migration patterns between the two
populations and for the and of course we
can assume whatever uh what we're what
we're doing right now is using a a uh
Matrix of migrations migration rates
between the uh the populations
Um this can potentially depend on time
and can therefore model post migrations
as
well um the framework is exactly the
same you get a you just get data that
includes sh a a multi-dimensional
distribution not just segments that are
shared between individuals but rather
segments that are shared between
individuals in each of the populations
or segments that are shared by
individuals across the two the two
populations you can write the it can
write the likelihood and
um and um apply ABC in order to infer
the the most likely parameters for for
the data um for the simpler scenario of
two populations that have been separate
practically practically forever and um
and have some fixed migration rate
between them H we see that we can uh we
can infer the migration rate uh here up
to 5% quite accurately as well as the
size of the of the
populations when
you when you add some more complexity
and have two populations of potentially
different sizes with asymmetric
migration and and potentially Astic
growth starting from a common ancestor
at some point G Generations ago in the
past um you can still follow the same
the same procedure and infer the uh
migration rates so this is kind of an
amalgamation of the accuracies for
different rates that are
that are all infered all infered ones as
well as the population sizes and these
are the the current population sizes
after after what's usually um population
growth that we see in many data
sets um so there's one more parameter
that that we may be interested in which
is the time to from from that um from
that um split event um and we considered
focusing on and and on looking at
different different ad
mixure different split times that
precede an a mixture event that was just
25 Generations before present in aetric
had mixture event with 80% from one
population and 20% of the gene flow from
another and we can play with
different with different split times in
order to try and try see and see how
that affects the the data
um in terms of the migration
um in terms of the a migration rate so
the total ER total contribution
of
um of of genetic content from this um
from this minority ancestral population
the 20% Group H we see that we're able
to infer that um pretty pretty
robustly for
different different split times even as
far back as as 500 600 Generations ago
uh and this is in comparison to to Carls
and Simon's pc pc ad mix and um and and
tracks on the same simulated
data
um so I promise you to look at some some
data um the data set
we the DAT set I'm about to talk about
is from The genome of the Netherlands
project um the data
includes 250 trios um across the
Netherlands this a map of Netherlands um
with the different provinces highlighted
and there are 11 provinces from which we
have um we have roughly the same number
of samples and we're considering the um
the parents from these trios so 500
individuals Al together and the data
itself is sequencing data to half depth
so
14x and so at least for the transmitted
Theos you have decent depth to to call
them even with a single look um
the um the data had been had been Trio
phased and called based on on a a
specific Trio Coler for that purpose and
so leveraging the design to the extent
possible um still we did not take in all
the all the variants that had been
called and we
only only thresholded variance at one 1%
or greater because for our purposes for
calling the segments this contained the
majority of information
and the rarer variants contained much
more noise so we prefer to prefer to
avoid them at this stage um still and
the well the genome is the cable genome
is large The cleanly colable genome is
shorter and every time we had regions
where we had concerns regarding
the the
depth or quality of the data we train
them out now when you do that and
analyze lengths of segments you need to
be very careful because the segments can
only reach that ER point of trimming so
we throw away H every um every remaining
bit of data bit of chromosome that was
less less than uh 50 c organs so
um were there were a few regions like
that that we had to throw away it
affected not just the regions but every
every part of the re part of the genome
that was potentially close to them uh we
try to be
careful careful
there um we so we
called regions of identif by descent
with with germline um the
so journaling is a tool that we
developed in our group when you're
looking at unfazed data it has its
issues with phase data we believe it
performs both fast and and relatively
accurately and here again we had Trio
phase data so we're able to use
that um so while we're looking we're
considering data from 11 provinces say
for many of the downstream analysis we
will consider the them as separated into
South Center and North provinces in
Netherlands I know there are couple of
Dutch people in the audience so uh
hopefully I'm getting that that part
right um the when you when you when you
try to consider each province separately
and infer a constant population size for
each um based
on relatively short segments of identi
by descent segments of one cent Morgan
till two to two cent Morgans H you you
see uh the north Netherland provinces
with the slightly
um slightly smaller population sizes uh
Center and in the MD middle and the
parts of south
south of the country have an inferred
larger population size and these are
relatively short IBD segments compared
to the others we've been looking at so
this is the more ancient history of the
country um when you consider the more
more recent history the segments that
are that are much longer we no longer
see this uh this pattern so this trend
whatever it is is something has
something to do with the
more the more more ancient history
history of a few a few thousands of
years
ago uh when we
consider
the the average number of
segments between every pair of provinces
across the state
this symmetric Matrix um or within each
each province across the diagonal H we
can do we can conduct this analysis at
different length thresholds or intervals
so these are the the
longest segments we we considered
segments of seven cmans and above and H
just to give you some orientation this
ER we have this time scale H at the
bottom the further the shorter the
segments the farther uh back in time
we're we would be going so if you squint
at the at this um hit map um you can see
that well the diagonal is a bit stronger
than everything else and things that are
off diagonal the far off diagonal are a
bit uh Greener so less H segments of
identi by descent when you go
farther in further and further back in
time so shorter and shorter segments and
you can see some Trends and some
surprising things so here let me draw
your attention to these two data points
between North Holland and freezeland
that in contrast to the overall pattern
and these two two provinces seem to
share a lot with one
another against the the overall pattern
moreover they they share more between
one another than North Holland shares
with itself and this hasn't been the
case for and for the more
recent and time frames so when we looked
at that
and mentioned that to our collaborators
um they showed us this ancient map of
the Netherlands where the there is
actually uh a reasonable land bridge
between these two provinces that is not
there today because of the changes in in
sea level so it's rewarding that you can
see this uh this relationship between
populations in a in accordance to the
time scale and that's relevant to the
actual events that led to that
um when you go further and further back
in time you see that the
overall the overall picture also changes
um yes the shorter segments you are
considering the more of them you see so
the numbers are getting bigger and
bigger but also
it's it's now no longer the case that
the diagonal is what's dominating the
picture but rather everybody is sharing
with the
north um we
moreover everybody's sharing with the
north more than they share with
themselves so we're trying to um come up
with ER with histories that that would
that would mimic that effect it's we
feel it's more robust to pull the
province
together so that we're actually
analyzing a 3X3 table of north south and
center with sufficient amounts
sufficient sample sizes and sufficient
numbers of segments in between each pair
of of populations um the the model that
is explained the data best is a serial
serial founder model where there is
overal migration from
the from the south to the center to the
north each population expanding
exponentially um the and with some
migration
going going on um
between South South Netherlands and the
center along the entire period um this
is not the only model that would give
rise to
to this particular history but in terms
of the parameter space that we have we
have explored this explains the data
best with with the Fest uh fewest
parameters so and yes okay population
structure in the South and the north is
there more population structure in the
South than the North ER I'm trying to
recall
the
um do it reminds me of I guess gr C's
not here today but in his IBD paper they
found there was like more IBD sharing
with Britain in Ireland and within
Britain and they thought that was
because like Britain has some Irish
people Irish like people and some others
and it was just more likely for like the
Irish type people to share with them
than to share with British people who
came from elsewhere so so saying well
the population of the northw so of the
South that we're that we're currently
looking atus if there's someth type
people there and some
others could be I don't remember the
exact statistics but but that makes
makes lots of sense that I think Iran
may be speaking to this uh trend of
migrations later
on
um so I I have two minutes three minutes
two all right uh so let's uh
let's spend two minutes talking about
sequence data
the the next thing about mutations Along
identi by descent segments is that well
they they are always along either of the
two lineages that lead from the common
ancestor to the two segments and the um
the number of mutations That You observe
would scale with the generation time to
the common answer and the length of the
segment now um we if we if you try to
estimate the uh the chance of observing
a observing a mutation that at a
particular a particular site that would
depend on
the that would be twice the the the
mutation rate per generation times the
number of generations um but the since
the length um um is is also a variable
the we need to integrate that
um um based on the um distribution of
the lengths of these segments that are
that are
exponential um and um you can you can
figure out that what's going on is that
there are mutations and re combination
events that may be coming and we're
waiting for the first
recombination event among these events
so it all boils down to just a geometric
distribution uh with uh with the chance
of mutation versus recombination so
mutation rate and recombination rate
play a part in this in defining this
process um most importantly this does
not depend on the generation time G it
just cancels out no matter whether the
condensor is ancient or more
recent if it's more recent we'll be
looking at shorter time for mutation but
longer regions for them to happen um
it's slightly more complicated when
we're considering the more practical
case where we're only looking at
segments above a particular length cut
off so um we're need we would have some
mutations within
that within that uh range till the
length cut off that would that mutations
that would we would need to count anyway
and those those would behave in as a
function of the generation time but
beyond that we'll still have this
competition between mutations and Rec
combination events waiting to the first
recombination from this point onwards so
H what we get out of this is
um is really um a function of both
generation time the generation time as
well as the geometric
distribution
but the um the final outcome is
something that's only weekly dependent
on the on the pop population history and
on the population size if we're modeling
a Conant a constant size
um more more specifically we can
um so we can practically look at
different population sizes and see that
well the total number of segments is
really a good a good indicate indicator
of the population size the number of
number of mutations that we see R barely
changes across this range of population
sizes in this case between 3,000 and and
almost 20,000
individuals um we can we can manipulate
the expression further to get rid of
this even small dependency on population
structure if we consider this segment
from it start at zero till the length
cut off youu and from the length cut
off onwards and sort the different
mutations to the two buckets the one
that depends on population size and the
one that doesn't and the bucket that
doesn't is
the and is only a function of mutation
rate so we can H at least in simulation
infer mutation rates uh based on uh
based on uh such data uh I'm I'm about
to be thrown out of here so uh let me
just say that in practice uh this had
served us more to estimate uh noise
rates than mutation rates but that's
already some some kind of information um
and just to sum up um the um identi by
descent is able to um to refer Dynamic
recent dynamics of one population or or
several within the Netherlands we see
the the expansion within each province
as well as the directional migration um
the when you incorporate sequence data
it's less informative regarding
the the historical patterns but it is
contributing information regarding
mutation rate a and the vast majority of
this work is by Pier palar who deserves
all the credit um I also want to thank
the our collaborators from the Gen of
the Netherlands primarily Laura fromi
who was really the the leading
persona for this effort as well as the
population genetics group s poit Elber
and Shamil group and and Paul debacker
who's been the MC here thank
you have for
questions Cate the rate the IBD segments
how much of an issue is it that the
detection of the IBD might be affected
by the mutations segment so if you have
more mutations you
might how much of an issue is that
detection of the IBD is affected by the
mutations so um in practice I I think
we're exploring beyond the limit of of
that ER of that question now because
right now we're seeing many more changes
between this many more differences
between segments than is practical to
expect as mutations many of the changes
we observe are are sequencing errors a
so I think in practice we're now in a
worse situation than
than than what you may be
concerned by the segments we're looking
at are long enough for for the
ascertainment I think to be of a just of
a secondary
effect y I'm also we're Curr extremely
interested in estimating mutation rates
and um uh a couple of comments uh first
of all your 14x coverage is not as I'm
sure you know not wonderful for what you
want to do um the uh um in our hands at
any rate we see substantially better
calls at 30X compared to 20x diploid
calls at 20 at 14x are not are not so
easy um that's just a comment but then
um do you think that with deeper data
maybe more data and maybe deeper sequen
you could really get a handle you could
get the error rate long low enough that
the mutation rate would really be
emerging think is a strong word I have
done the simulation to to evaluate the
answer is
no um
the um I think the I think there's hope
to get so it's a to get
the to get the information content from
a few thousands of false positive
Singletons per genome if you go down to
um to a TH or 2,000 then then you're
already in in an interesting range here
because within each segment you
expect very few